and I go over and I see this people
freaking out about the Jonas Brothers
these kids are losing their mind but I'm
not necessarily a fan of the music
um so I thought man there needs to be a
kid who sings
great Angelic songs the way Michael
Jackson did because that Angelic voice
will make you believe in love again
before you got jaded so I had this idea
of who that kid was and that's when I
saw Justin I'm like that's the kid we
saw him just on YouTube yeah middle of
the night I went on to consult I was
making extra money Consulting other
people I was Consulting acon on another
artist and I clicked on Justin's video
by mistake and I was like that's the kid